Prototypes come in various forms.
Some are paper, some are clickable
screens, some are built using code.
No matter the medium,
one thing these prototypes have in
common is their intended purpose.
The core purpose of a prototype is to
help you communicate the story of your
app to your stake holders for
feedback or research sessions.
This stops you from wasting time
building a really polished product
that has really glaring flaws.
Prototyping is not just
specific to the tech industry.
Product design companies and
car manufacturers have been utilizing
prototypes from the very beginning.
Prototyping is a way to help you
make the best decisions possible
around the user experience
of your product.
Helps you make key decisions and help
you build better products through moving
through various stages,
which we'll talk about later.
It's been said that an estimated
50% of engineering time
is spent doing rework that
could've been avoided.
What's more, fixing an error after
development is up to 100 times
as expensive as it would've been before.
Customers who have a positive user
experience are going to be more likely
to stick with your products and
become your brand advocates.
Now let's take a look at the various
stages of prototyping that we'll cover
in this course.